welcome back Brittany that is awesome
welcome back Fritzi you were down some
say you were out I had total faith in
you that you would pull through and
thank God the Dan nets are reunited once
again right back knock hotter welcome
back for red you called Fritzi soft last
week you went how long's Fritzi been out
and i went two weeks and you went two
weeks soft what I really meant to say it
was risky i apologize i don't know what
got something got the best of me but I'm
glad you're back I'm glad we're all
reunited thanks bud reg will be calling
the Timberwolves at the Raptors coming
up thursday night at 27 eastern on tnt
all right klay Thompson lights it up 60
and 29 minutes of work should sow should
steve curve lefty men reg the basketball
part of me the 18-year vet of course you
want to stay in there of course I'm
going to go to my coach and say let me
play the least the first four or five
minutes of the fourth that's the
basketball part the analysts not wanting
to tinker or mess with the basketball
gods you can't do that number one you're
up by 30 plus points and you were
getting wherever you want it and
whatever shot you wanted you never want
to piss off the basketball gods and I
kind of go back to and again this is not
Tom Thibodeau's Falls but Kevin Harlan
and I were doing a playoff game when
Derrick Rose very first injured and tore
his ACL and that playoff game vs
philadelphia it was Game one they were
up 14 15 points with like a minute left
normally you scrub the benches you take
your starters out and it's a playoff
game anyways fib didn't do that well you
know what happened to Derrick Rose if
you're Steve Kerr
damned if you do damned if you don't
because of course the player wants to
stay in what's the endgame 6570 what's
the flipside a ACL turned ankle broken
there's so many things that could go
wrong steve kerr err on the side of the
basketball gods smart decisions you've
got 60 in 29 minutes that's baller that
is balling how many do you think he
could have had lunch 70 okay she left
them up he left them on the table first
of all you mean if you went back in yeah
would say 70 he left money on the table
he missed two wide-open threes he missed
that free-throw late so I mean that's 67
right there if he plays three or four
minutes in the fourth let's tack on
another four to five points but let me
just say this I love when shooters and
scores go crazy like Steph way Damian
Lillard look it's it's great now let me
put on my adopted who's your hat what
the hell are y'all doing are you serious
you are you not going to this his but
never touched the floor one time in that
game if you're Larry Bird you got to be
rolling over in your grave right now
watching that game wait wait lera
Larry's Larry's not dead I know but
that's a speech at all you got is you
guys you rolling old you know you rollin
over man are you kidding me yet I'm
trying to be objective here but for me
to play 18 years with one team that
can't happen I would have found out he
played 29 minutes I would have found out
in the first 10 minutes trying to kill
this dude he did not touch the floor one
time that's embarrassing but II but on
the flip side I like seeing it we get me
wrong I love seeing it I've done it and
i've been i've been knocked down on my
behind during that game clay never
touched the deck one time in that game
could anybody else currently in the NBA
have lobbied their coach to stay in the
game
that was a blow and they had and they're
sitting on 60 LeBron i'm gonna guess if
he's got 60 going into the fourth
quarter they're up by 20 i'm guessing
maybe uh DeMar DeRozan I'm guessing
maybe a Damian Lillard a boogie cousins
would he just wouldn't listen to the
coach need to stand right well he does
that mainly that's nothing new for
Brooke you know he's making no kind
decision on a nightly basis but to have
60 and going into the fourth in a blog
now Kobe could do it um and I believe
got wall when Kobe got the would he get
71 he won what did I get anyone when he
got the 81 but it wasn't uh a blowout it
was within 10 to 15 points yes wait wait
I can understand why he's still on the
floor um but 60 up 30-plus I never want
to mess with the basketball gods because
they always come back and to me what's
the end game well you just have one of
those magical yeah one of those magical
nights but you know a it doesn't it
sound better 60 and 29 versus what 63 in
33 know that kind of Renshi right red
reg if he goes back in you know they're
going to give him the ball and he's
going to get a chest 70 sounds pretty
cool sixties nice dad okay and that's
the point I'm making about the Indiana
Pacers if that would have been me versus
the New York Knicks and i'm sitting on
60 and i'm going back in and i'm up by
30 trying to embarrass them yeah not
that he's trying to embarrass them but
you are unintentionally embarrassing
them that's when guys get taken out out
the air and you don't see that anymore
in today's game because we have review
and all that back in the day someone
would seriously got hurt seriously
you've got to put some love taps on them
so don't don't tinker with the
basketball gods because they're gonna be
a game where it's close and you're
sitting on 45-50 where they really need
those shots that's when the basketball
guards are going to reward Steve Kerr
and you're golden
a warrior's because of that decision of
taking him out he said Reggie Miller
Reggie got Timberwolves at the Raptors
coming up thursday night seven Eastern
on TNT what is Charles Barkley mean when
he refers to the warrior style is little
girly basketball well I i I'm as much as
I love Charles I'm shocked because if
that's the case all 30 teams are playing
girly ball if Gurley ball is shooting
threes and playing perimeter that's the
NBA today that there is no lo posts back
to the basket players teams a little bit
Memphis because of Zach maybe Marcus all
a little bit I would even say San
Antonio because LaMarcus Aldridge at 610
611 he's still I mean he could play with
us back to the bathroom JumpShip yeah
yeah he's a jump shooter so if the
Warriors play girly basketball then
everyone's playing girly basketball
because they're there are no longer
those teams is Houston a girly
basketball team the Spurs I mean the
Clippers they play Lob City I mean who's
playing with her back to the basket I
mean Charles at times he and it it's
okay you've got to let go of the past I
mean this is what what the cane is then
well he's just trolling people's always
doing read it but it's the NBA now it's
all about threes and third there aren't
really think about what teams play with
their back play low post basketball I
mean karl-anthony challenges great of a
young talent SD is Minnesota isn't he's
shooting threes for zynga's shooting
threes Bobby what big man are you or do
you want two plays like big boy
basketball there aren't any anymore so I
think that's what probably is catching
people off guard is like you're calling
them girly basketball but that's what
everyone is doing i'm watching porzingis
the other night and he's taken somebody
off the dribble he's 74 and he is
wonderful crossing he's crossing over
taking somebody off the dribble well it
shows you the evolution not only of our
game but of our players and that goes to
Charles this point you know Charles was
great as handling the basketball for his
eyes at 64 65 and I'm being generous and
he could take guys off the dribbles but
Dirk he revolutionized the big man at
that power forward slash center position
with shooting and before the injuries to
dirt being able to take a few dribbles
and you know the fade away and the high
arcing foot I mean you see guys like
Durant kind of annihilating you know his
moves and so forth so he changed that
whole power forward position with the
ability to stretch the floor open up the
floor and we're kind of seeing the two
point O version and porzingis reg is
going to toronto with the timbrel Mike
Timberwolves and they've been a
disappointment here in LA they did have
a big win on the road this week in
charlotte in overtime but again it to me
with minnesota it's all about a learning
curve and you've got great young talent
i mentioned cat Wiggins done who should
be getting more burn Rubio Zach Lavine
it's all of Zach Lavine who's played
fantastic these guys they got to figure
out how to win and that's the hardest
part with a young team and when you've
got an old Bulldog type coach like Tom
Thibodeau I have to show a lot of
patience but I think at the end of the
day not this year but give them a year
or two they are going to be fighting you
know you know for our top four spot in
the Western Conference because of that
young talent safe travels to Toronto
Theodore you are truly the best I am so
excited that my man my man is that the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]